this sports gods up in the clouds in
another dimension we join them now at
their monthly meeting so yeah
tube holds a big hit obviously everybody
lo'ed that little twist ending and
football remains America's favorite
pastime so who did deflate those
footballs your mom Oh football
hey hockey hockey two minutes but cool
down for budget alright alright so that
wraps it up for pro football this year
nice job I stopped ah basketball why
don't you give us a rundown of what you
got planned for the rest of the season
I've got nothing
what do you mean you have no I don't
know it I've hit a wall nothing wrong
with that
what do you mean basketball you've hit a
wall well the last few years the Spurs
of the heat it was great stuff you know
but now I'm feeling a lot of pressure to
top that I feel like I need something
fresh something special but I also don't
want to come off as desperate like
hockey you know what I'm saying hey
basically I'm stuck oh he's a spot vidi
amaz I avow today you know what that is
a great idea highlight does anyone have
any suggestions for basketball let's
let's help him workshop this there's no
such thing as a stupid idea
alright I'll take a swing at this what
if we made the team with the lower score
win boom there it is problem solved
moving any other suggestions guys for
basketball yeah what if you gives it
blares weapons you could put them on
horses on imagina Lee Manos para teres
Lagos interested all right guys guys
we're not changing basketballs rules
here okay that's for mortals to the
sides
how many tells me to go through this
okay where basketball is to focus on the
individual superstars you should reward
a true team likes it like the hoops
I think the wet boys should win it all
the wet boys what yeah you know the wet
boards clay oh yeah you mean the splash
brothers shared
splash fries I like they owe me too
now hear me out though okay so we have a
thing in bowling it's called a turkey
and it's three strikes in a row what if
you had three three-pointers in a row
you gave it a bird named walk all I can
eat grass or a puppet or a Warbler or
Mac Eagle penguin oh you done this is
not a bird I think what basketballs
looking for is drama okay
did somebody see drama
I know drama better than anyone here's
my scenario to save Basketball
Federation I I don't need to be saved
I'm just open to it the Rockets are
playing the kills James hard-on screwed
up the north
somebody snapped a match the king is
dead the king is he's not dead what in
God's name the king is not dead
true the singer comes in another layer
now
no I don't believe I don't believe it no
Aaron thought it was retired car
convert the Chicago Bulls win the
champion an Air Jordan takes home his
seventh belt and you're getting some of
my small bright
all right basketball any of these ideas
jumping out of you um no I'm just gonna
make the Spurs win again thanks guys
[Music]